Харків для мене — це місто мрій,
місто всіляких експериментів у будь-чому.
Тобто це якийсь котел,
де постійно вирують творчі ідеї.
Якби когось із просунутої молоді спитали:
«А де, взагалі, тут місце, якась локація,
де постійно відбуваються якісь
дуже круті й цікаві мистецькі заходи?»,
то вам одразу скажуть,
що це Харківський ЛітМузей,
що це садок літературного музею.
Музей створили 1988 року харківські ентузіасти,
члени Харківської спілки письменників України.
Перший музей був ще тоді,
як Харків був столицею
Радянської України, у 1930-ті роки.
Насправді тут було таке місце сили в Харкові,
де всі вони творили.
Але, на жаль, почалися репресії,
і цей музей залишився тільки в ідеях.
Перша велика виставка музею
називалася «Українська Голгофа».
Про письменників 1920-30-х років.
Мета: розповісти саме про те, що замовчували,
про «розстріляне відродження»,
нагадати всім, що Харків — це, насправді,
місто літератури, мистецтва.
Усі ці великі письменники і художники
тут жили, творили.
Просто ми зараз усе це забуваємо.
Забуваємо, що в нас є Будинок «Слово»,
де вони всі жили.
Наша колекція складається зараз
із більш ніж 40 000 експонатів.
Це якраз архіви цих письменників,
які нам передавали вже їхні діти, онуки.
Архів Івана Дніпровського, Миколи Куліша,
листування Леся Курбаса,
особисті речі, наприклад,
пенсне Павла Тичини, його костюм.
Це також архіви харківських дисидентів,
письменників 1960-х років,
архіви 1990-х років, сучасної української літератури,
і взагалі письменників сучасної України,
які до нас приїжджають у гості,
залишають свої книжки
з автографами, рукописи, фотографії.
Ми активно почали читати
письменників 1920-х років.
Для нас це був абсолютний шок,
тому що ми не думали,
що українська література має
таку європейську, інтелектуальну художню
височенного рівня новаторську літературу.
Дуже багато новаторських течій тут народилося,
а потім перейшло на Захід.
А тепер ми досліджуємо це як західні віяння.
Це в нас невеличка експозиція
про Івана Дніпровського,
письменника теж «розстріляного відродження».
Але так вийшло, що він помер
до початку великих репресій.
Він помер від туберкульозу.
Він захворів, коли був солдатом
під час Першої світової війни.
І потім все життя лікувався.
Він був дуже плодовитий письменник.
Після нього залишилося
дуже багато листувань, рукописів,
тому що він був також театральним письменником.
Багато ставили п'єс у той час.
Але свій архів він заповів знищити
своїй дружині Марії Пилинській.
Проте після його смерті вона
не знищила архів, а зберегла.
Зберегла під час репресій,
під час Другої світової війни.
Завдяки цьому ми дуже багато
дізналися про 1920-ті роки,
побачили перелік мешканців Будинку «Слово»,
і невідомі рукописи Миколи Хвильового,
і дуже багато цінного листування і речей.
Це — диван Тичини.
Легендарний диван.
І вже коли хтось із письменників
приїжджає, то виникла така традиція,
коли будь-який письменник для того,
щоб надихнутися,
обов'язково має посидіти на цьому дивані.
З 1917 року вже почалася реквізиція.
Бібліотека 1920 року: постанови Головліт,
через яке проходили всі книжки
на доступ у суспільстві чи ні.
Оскільки вже була запрограмована
ось ця модель нової радянської людини.
І під неї мав бути дозволений
чи недозволений певний контент.
І далі йдуть 1950-60-ті роки,
коли, з одного боку, багато хто
виїжджає і починається в діаспорі,
знову українець звільняється,
і починається справжня творчість.
А нагорі — ідеологеми совєцької людини,
дружби України й Росії.
1954 рік — представлення Шевченка
як пролетарського письменника.
Тобто все у винятково
жорстких рамках дозволеного,
що абсолютно не відповідає
ні вільній творчості, ні власне правді.
[Cергій Жадан читає свою поезію]
«Якщо ви всі прорветесь і уникнете облав,
якщо загубитесь у чужих містах,
ви все одно не зможете бути щасливими там,
де вас ніхто не чекав.
Вигнання завжди обертається тишею на вустах.
Я розумію, що ти не хочеш жити між бід і пожеж,
розумію, що тобі заважає кожна з моїх загорож.
Можна втекти від мене,
але від себе ти ж не втечеш.
Та й від мене, якщо відверто,
не втечеш також».
Можна сказати, що саме зі знайомства
з ЛітМузеєм у 1990-х роках,
з тим першим складом співробітників,
почалася творчість Сергія Жадана, Ігора Пилипчука,
Ростислава Мельникова і багатьох тих,
тих, хто приїжджав сюди в гості.
Усі гуртувалися в літературному музеї,
тому що тоді на мапі Харкова він був
таким місцем українства, українознавства.
Можна сказати, що ЛітМузей
в якомусь сенсі зробив такого Жадана,
якого ми зараз знаємо.
Я навчався в Харківській академії
культури на музеєзнавця.
До того декілька разів був у ЛітМузеї і зрозумів,
що зі всіх музеїв Харкова мені хотілося би
працювати саме в цьому.
Бо він найбільше відрізнявся від усіх музеїв.
Ми завжди позиціонували себе
як такий живий музей,
бо в нас завжди різна аудиторія,
різні заходи,
щоб людям було цікаво,
і самим співробітникам було цікаво
тут працювати і робити щось нове.
Це — проєкт нашого художника Нікіти Тітова
і молодого харківського поета Івана Сеніна.
У них почався такий проєкт,
що Іван Сенін писав якийсь вірш,
а Нікіта Тітов малював до нього ілюстрацію.
І, навпаки, Нікіта писав вірш,
а Сенін спробував намалювати ілюстрацію.
У них створився такий мистецький діалог,
і сьогодні вони презентували його в садку ЛітМузею.
Ще з 1990-х це місце було особливим для літературного,
культурного, мистецького життя Харкова.
Тут проводиться багато абсолютно різноманітних
як і літературних проєктів, виступів,
так і загалом різних мистецьких
і музичних невеличких фестивалів.
Була «Ніч у музеї» два чи навіть три роки тому,
і музей до мене звернувся саме
з приводу айдентики цієї події.
Я прийшов з ідеями, запропонував,
що музей — це космос, а не нафталін.
Але взагалі-то про музеї в мене була така думка,
що це вже якась нафталінова історія.
Я прийшов із цим слоганом, і мені сказали:
«Блін, це круто! Давай робити».
Ми намалювали бабусю на стільчику,
яка злітає в космос.
Це вийшло доволі прикольно.
У багатьох людей з протилежними
ідеологіями, які живуть у Харкові,
є розуміння того, що це — сховище
нашої спільної історичної пам'яті.
Ми даємо можливість різним групам,
різним середовищам
знайти між собою консенсус
у живій дискусії, а не в бійках між собою.
Ми себе ідентифікуємо не тільки через мову,
але й через власну культуру,
яку ми переосмислюємо на сьогодні також.
І вона дає нам потенцію і можливості
розвивати українську культуру далі.